[Music]
we have a bit of history yeah that we
should probably cop to right up top
which is that back in the day when we
were doing a show in New York the late
night show you were an intern for us I
was an intern in 1997 mm-hmm and I was
it was it I hope it was a good
experience it was it was I was a control
room intern and I didn't you're a
college kid when you're an intern you
don't know how to do anything and I had
one no really you know you don't know
any do anything and so they I had one
responsibility they said there's that
see that phone if that phone rings and
it's Rick bring it to us immediately
and I was like got it well that phone
never rang three months I did literally
nothing right like when I went to
interviews after I left the show they
would be like you have experience
answering phones and I would say kind of
I'm aware of what a phone is and if Rick
calls I know what to do I've never
actually done the thing and yeah no it
was a great experience I feel very lucky
yeah sure yeah no but did you know even
at the time when you were interning for
us that you wanted to go into comedy
were you yeah that you've always been
interested my dream when I was a group
in Massachusetts and I was a big fan of
yours and you know you went to Harvard
and everything we were in the heart on
the Harvard Lampoon you ran it and
that's what I wanted to do and so I
applied to Harvard you applied to
Harvard just because you wanted to get
comedy that's the only reason I thought
of myself like a basketball player where
I was like they'll want me
they're gonna need me and I thought all
of the hi and also I thought Harvard's a
good fit you know when you're applying
to colleges you don't go for the best
school mm-hmm you go for the school
that's really fits like a glove and I
thought me and Harvard me and Harvard
really felt like it so and so what I did
was I I didn't really have the grades of
the SATs or the activities to get in the
you know the way yeah so you know
obsessed with statistics and numbers and
although I hear yeah well I went to the
interview and I thought this is gonna be
like my home run derby I'm just gonna
knock him out of the park and show them
I brought a big stack of satire comedy
writing pieces I had done in high school
and I showed up and I was livid the
woman I was like this is what I this is
what I wrote and she was this woman
she's a lawyer very serious lady and she
was like okay thanks and she put those
off to the side she didn't seem like she
was gonna read them yeah or really give
this she didn't give a sense sheet she
intended to read them more wanted to
read them or and so I put those off to
the side and she goes is there any other
reason you want to go to Harvard other
than to write comedy right and this is
this is one of the boldest moments in my
life I said no there is no other reason
that I want to go to Harvard and I was
rejected but I feel like
I feel like in retrospect I feel like
you know it's a it's a select Club of us
yeah this group of people who either
left Harvard or never went to Harvard in
the first place
you got you got your Bill Gates got
Zuckerberg you got a Robert Frost yeah
for Biglia you got all of the big
leaders we got all of her big Lea's
family and friends and we get together
every year and we're just like haha
remember how we didn't go to Harvard for
the full amount of time and they at this
year I was asked to be in the Harvard
Lampoon as an honorary member who won
anyway the point of the story is few
Harvard
on behalf of Conan O'Brien and Mike
Birbiglia we want to say you Harvard go
ahead sure yeah that's not real by the
way the fake one you now as pig breeding
bird play that's what they all say